This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantu. We begin today's show in a snowy Midwestern school yard. A group of boys is gathered around a flat pole. One is daring the other to stick his tongue to the icy metal. Are you getting stuck my tongue to a stupid, polite dog? That's got no stick. He folded. Oh yeah!
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们今天的节目从一个下雪的中西部学校操场开始。一群男孩聚在一根扁平的杆子周围。其中一个在激另一个把舌头贴在冰冷的金属上。你是不是在怂恿我把舌头贴在愚蠢、礼貌的狗身上？那一点都不粘。他认怂了。哦，耶！
Yeah! A lot of double dog dare you! If you've seen the film A Christmas Story, you know where this is headed. The double dog dare escalates to a triple dog dare, which ends, no surprise here, with a boy's tongue stuck to a flagpole. Okay, that's just the movies. Many of us like to think we'd never succumb to the sort of peer pressure. We believe we're independent thinkers that our choices are our own. our values and preferences are inherent to our personalities, not the whims and wishes of others.
耶！有很多双倍真心话大冒险！如果你看过电影《圣诞故事》，你就会知道接下来会发生什么。双倍真心话大冒险升级成了三倍真心话大冒险，不出所料，结局是一个男孩的舌头被粘在了旗杆上。好吧，那只是电影。我们许多人喜欢认为自己绝不会屈服于这种同辈压力。我们相信自己是独立的思想者，我们的选择是自主的。我们的价值观和偏好是我们个性固有的，而不是受他人一时兴起和愿望的左右。
It turns out though that reality is a bit more complicated. Everywhere in life, at work at school, at a sports game in a big stadium with thousands of other people, at home in the privacy of our own bedrooms, our behavior is constantly shaped by the judgments, norms, and actions of other people. Sometimes we can feel this influence, such as when our tongue is tucked to an icy flagpole. But more often than not, these influences are so subtle, we don't even notice their existence. My guest today has spent a lot of time thinking about these forces that act on us. And these influences are so subtle, we don't even notice their existence. My guest today has spent a lot of time thinking about these forces that act on us.
然而事实证明，现实要复杂一些。生活中的处处地方——在工作单位、在学校、在坐满成千上万其他人的体育场里、在家里我们自己的卧室里——我们的行为不断受到其他人的判断、规范和行动的影响。有时我们能感受到这种影响，比如当我们的舌头贴在冰冷的旗杆上时。但更多时候，这些影响是如此微妙，以至于我们甚至没有注意到它们的存在。我今天的嘉宾花了很多时间思考这些对我们起作用的力量。这些影响是如此微妙，以至于我们甚至没有注意到它们的存在。我今天的嘉宾花了很多时间思考这些对我们起作用的力量。
Jonah Berger is a marketing professor at the University of Pennsylvania and the author of the book Invisible Influence, the hidden forces that shape behavior. Jonah, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. Companies often pay celebrities to hawk their merchandise, so I often see athletes wearing clothes with a Nike swoosh. Tiffany apparently once paid Anne Hathaway $750,000 to wear its jewelry at the Oscars. But a few years ago, you tell the story of how Apacromy and Fitch made an unusual offer to the stars of Jersey Shore.
乔纳·伯杰是宾夕法尼亚大学的市场营销教授，也是《隐形影响力：塑造行为的隐藏力量》一书的作者。乔纳，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。公司经常花钱请名人来推销他们的商品，所以我经常看到运动员穿着带有耐克钩形标志的衣服。蒂芙尼显然曾在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上支付给安妮·海瑟薇 75 万美元让她佩戴他们的珠宝。但几年前，你讲过一个关于阿贝克隆比和费奇（Abercrombie & Fitch）如何向《泽西海岸》的明星们提出一项不同寻常的报价的故事。
What was that offer? So you may remember the Jersey Shore, sort of a bunch of early 20s folks, lots of fake Tanner and big muscles. I was in the Jacuzzi and closed just started coming off, so we decided to have a little fun. And one of them was a guy named Mike, the situation Sorrentino,
那是什么报价？所以你可能还记得《泽西海岸》，里面是一群二十出头的人，有很多假美黑和健硕的肌肉。当时我在按摩浴缸里，衣服开始掉下来，所以我们决定找点乐子。其中一个是叫迈克的人，绰号“局势”索伦蒂诺，
and he was called the situation for his famous abs you can hate on the all you want to but what can you possibly say somebody that looks like rambo pretty much with a shirt off and uh... apricot being fit sent him a letter uh... offering to pay him money and that by itself is not unusual right as you mentioned product placement is a major thing that that companies often use
他因为腹肌出名而被叫做“局势”。不管你怎么讨厌他，但对于一个脱掉衬衣就像兰博一样的人，你能说什么呢？呃……阿贝克隆比和费奇给他写了一封信，呃……提出付钱给他，单是这一点并不罕见，对吧？正如你所提到的，产品植入是公司经常使用的一个主要手段。
what was interesting about this letter though was they weren't offering to pay him money to wear their clothes. They were actually paying him not to wear their clothes. And it turns out he wasn't the only Jersey Shore cast member who had a recent run in with a brand. Another cast member, Snooki. She was the short one you may remember who's been termed as looking like a parking cone
不过这封信有趣的地方在于，他们不是付钱让他穿他们的衣服。实际上他们是付钱让他不要穿他们的衣服。事实证明，他并不是最近与某个品牌产生交集的《泽西海岸》演员中的唯一一个。另一个演员，斯努基。你可能还记得那个个子矮的，因为用了太多橙色假美黑而被形容为看起来像一个停车锥的家伙。
because she wore so much orange fake tanner. She got a free handbag in the mail. And obviously, again, sending a free handbag make sense. Brands may want to send it to her because she shows up in People magazine or in touch and because she's wearing it. Other people might wear the brand. Except she got a Gucci handbag, not from Gucci,
她在邮箱里收到了一个免费手袋。显然，再次强调，寄一个免费手袋是合乎情理的。品牌可能会想把手袋寄给她，因为她会出现在《人物》杂志或《In Touch》杂志上，而且因为她戴着它，其他人可能会购买这个品牌。但她收到的是一个古驰手袋，不是来自古驰，
but one of their competitors. And so why would a competitor send her a free handbag? Why would Abrahamian Fitch offer to pay Mike the situation not to wear their clothes? And it turns out influence is very much like a magnet. We often think about it attracting, doing the same thing as others. But just it often repels us and leads us to the opposite.
而是来自他们的竞争对手。那么，为什么竞争对手会给她免费寄一个手袋呢？为什么阿贝克隆比和费奇会出钱让迈克“局势”不要穿他们的衣服呢？事实证明，影响力非常像一块磁铁。我们经常认为它具有吸引力，让我们去做和别人一样的事情。但它也经常排斥我们，引导我们走向相反的方向。
And the idea here is, well, if Mike the situation is wearing Abercrombian Fitch, maybe other people aren't going to want to wear it anymore. Or if Snookies hanging on to a Gucci handbag, maybe that'll help their competitors because no one will want to wear Gucci anymore. Or if Snookies hang on to a Gucci handbag, maybe that'll help their competitors because no one will want to wear Gucci anymore. So we need to understand how social it was attracts, but also how it repels.
这里的想法是，如果迈克“局势”穿着阿贝克隆比和费奇的衣服，也许其他人就会不想再穿了。或者如果斯努基拿着一个古驰手袋，也许这会对他们的竞争对手有帮助，因为没有人会想再穿古驰了。或者如果斯努基拿着一个古驰手袋，也许这会对他们的竞争对手有帮助，因为没有人会想再穿古驰了。所以我们需要理解社交网络是如何吸引的，同时也要理解它是如何排斥的。
UN Chip Heath at Stanford University ran a similar experiment some years ago, and this one involved wristbands. Walk me through what you did and what you found. This is one of my first studies that I ran early on in graduate school. You may remember these yellow live strong wristbands. They were for Lance Armstrong's live strong foundation.
几年前，斯坦福大学的奇普·希思做了一个类似的实验，这次实验涉及腕带。请向我介绍一下你们做了什么以及发现了什么。这是我在研究生院早期开展的最早的研究之一。你可能还记得这些黄色的“坚强生活”腕带。它们是为兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的“坚强生活”基金会制作的。
And they came out, they were, people were quite interested in them at the beginning. We sold them to a group on campus. So we would knock down doors. We said, hey, we're raising money for cancer awareness. Will you buy one of these wristbands and wear it for a dollar? Most people said, yes, they were more than happy to wear it. We followed up a week later to see if many people were wearing them, they were, so indeed people were wearing the wristband, and then we did something interesting. We sold them to a dorm next door,
它们刚推出时，人们一开始对它们相当感兴趣。我们将它们卖给校园里的一个群体。我们会敲门。我们说，嘿，我们正在为癌症意识筹款。你愿意花一美元买其中一个腕带并戴上它吗？大多数人说愿意，他们非常乐意戴上它。一周后我们进行回访，看看是不是有很多人在戴，结果确实在戴，人们确实戴着这个腕带，然后我们做了一件有趣的事。我们把它们卖给了隔壁宿舍，
and we wanted to see similar to this example of Mike the situation wearing Abercrombie or a snookie carrying Gucci handbag, how would people feel with other people they didn't want to be associated with, started wearing the bands. So So there's a dorm on Stanford campus, sort of known as the geeky dorm on campus. And basically we went next door and we sold these wristbands to the geeks. And so the question was, what would those original wristband wears do,
我们想看看，类似于迈克“局势”穿着阿贝克隆比或斯努基拎着古驰手袋的例子，当那些人们不想与之产生关联的其他人开始佩戴这些腕带时，人们会有什么感觉。所以，斯坦福校园里有一个宿舍，在校园里有点被称为书呆子宿舍。基本上我们走到隔壁，把这些腕带卖给了书呆子们。所以问题是，那些最初的腕带佩戴者会怎么做，
the people that liked the wristband that were wearing it all the time, do once the geeks started wearing it? And sure enough, as soon as the geeks started wearing it, about a third of the people in that initial group stopped wearing it. And they stopped because they didn't want to be associated with the geeks, right? Once those geeky folks were doing it, they didn't want to do it anymore. So what you're really saying is that one really effective way to get people to buy your
那些喜欢腕带并一直戴着它的人，一旦书呆子们开始戴上它，他们会怎么做？果不其然，一旦书呆子们开始戴上它，最初那个群体中大约三分之一的人就停止佩戴了。他们停下来是因为他们不想和书呆子们扯上关系，对吧？一旦那些书呆子在做这件事，他们就不想再做了。所以你真正要说的是，让人们购买你的
brand or buy your product is make sure that the people they despise are buying other brands. Is that what you're saying? A little bit. Yeah, we often think about sort of aspirational identities. So, Abercrombie shows people that we might want to look like in their ads. But we think a lot less about, well, what might people want to avoid? Right? Might people want to avoid doing something if other people are doing it? We did another study with health behavior showing people actually avoided
品牌或购买你的产品的一个非常有效的方法，就是确保他们鄙视的人在买别的品牌。这就是你想表达的吗？有一点吧。是的，我们经常考虑某种追求向往的身份认同。所以，阿贝克隆比在广告中展示了我们可能想要成为的外表。但我们很少去考虑，人们可能会想要避开什么？对吧？如果别人在做某事，人们会不会想要避免去做？我们对健康行为进行了另一项研究，表明当我们将大学生的过度饮酒行为与他们不想要的身份联系起来时，他们实际上避免了过度饮酒。因此，这不仅关乎将事物与期望的行为联系起来以促使人们去做，还关乎如何将不期望的行为与不期望的身份联系起来，并利用这一点来阻止人们做错事。社会心理学整个领域有趣的事情之一——你在书中对此进行了相当篇幅的讨论——是人们看不到自己，就像他们看别人那么清楚。或者他们看待自己和自己的选择时，
binge drinking in college when we associated with an identity that was undesired for them. And so, it's not just about associating things with desired behaviors to get people to do it. It's also about saying, well, how can we associate undesired behaviors with undesired identities and use that to avoid people doing the wrong thing? One of the interesting things about the entire field of social psychology, and you talk about this at some length in the book, is the idea that people don't see themselves as clearly as they see other people. Or they see themselves in their choices differently
与看待其他人做出的相同选择方式不同。部分原因是我们了解自己购买物品原因的渠道不同。当我们环顾四周时，我们看到许多人在做类似的事情。我的意思是，归根结底，我们其实都挺相似的，对吧？我们大多数人都不像 Lady Gaga 那样穿着肉片装到处走。
than the same choices made by other people. And part of that is the access we have to the reasons that we bought things. When we look around, we see lots of people doing similar things. I mean, at the end of the day, we're all pretty similar, right? Most of us are not like Lady Gaga walking around in a meat dress.
我们大多数人穿的是短裤和T恤、牛仔裤和有领衬衫。大家的穿着都挺相似的。我们开相似的车。我们买相似的东西。所以，确实，当我们环顾四周时，我们看到很多人在做出相似的行为。我们看到了影响力的存在并认为它正在发生。
Most of us are wearing shorts and t-shirts, jeans in a collared shirt. Dress pretty similarly. We drive similar cars. We buy similar things. And so, indeed, when we look around, we see a lot of people acting similarly. And we see influence and assume it's happening.
然而，当我们审视自我时，我们依赖于内省。我们不仅会问，我的行为是怎样的？我做了什么？我们还会寻找证据，证明我们那样做是有原因的。因为当我们思考时，好吧，我不认为我买那辆车是为了融入群体。
When we look to ourselves, though, we look to our introspection. We don't just say, well, what did I behave? What did I do? But we look for evidence that there's a reason that we behave that way. And because when we think about it, well, I don't think I bought that card to fit in.
我当时并没有坐在那儿想，天哪，我真的很想跟上潮流。你以为你买它是出于价格考虑，或者你以为买它是出于你喜欢它的外观。所以你认为这并没有影响你自己的行为。尽管归根结底，它确实产生了影响。你在书中讲了一个关于你的一位律师朋友的故事，他对年轻律师以及他们的宝马车有一些强烈的看法。
I wasn't sitting there going, God, I really want to keep up with the Joneses. You thought you bought it because of price or you thought you bought it because you liked how it looked. So you don't think it affected your own behavior. Even though at the end of the day, it actually did. You're trying to story in the book about a friend of yours who's a lawyer, and he has some strong views about younger lawyers and their BMWs.
是的，当时我在写这本书，我跟我的一个好朋友聊天，他是华盛顿特区人，恰好是一名律师。我跟他们讲了社会影响力，他们感叹社会影响力对同龄人的影响，他们说，天哪，所有华盛顿特区的律师都一个样。他们飞黄腾达了，成了合伙人，诸如此类。然后他们就会出去买一辆崭新的宝马。我说，嗯，这挺有意思的。
Yeah, so I was writing this book and I was talking to a good friend of mine who's from Washington, DC, and they happen to be a lawyer. And I was telling them about social influence, and they were lamenting the impact of social influence on their peers, and they were saying, God, all DC lawyers are the same. They make it big, they become partner, whatever it is. And they go out and they buy a new BMW. And I said, well, that's interesting.
但你难道不是华盛顿特区的律师吗？我对我的朋友说，而且你也开宝马。他说，哦，对，对，对。但是他们——你知道的，难道你不也开宝马吗？他说，哦，对，对，对。但是，你知道的，他们开的都是灰色的，而我开的是蓝色的。呃，我当时坐在那儿想，好吧，随你怎么说。但我喜欢那个故事的两点在于，对吧？第一，同样地，我们看到了影响力，对吧？
But aren't you a DC lawyer? I said to my friend, and you drive a BMW also. And he said, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. But they and you know, don't you drive a BMW also? And he said, oh yeah, yeah, yeah. But, you know, they all drive gray ones, and I drive a blue one. Uh, and I was sitting there going, okay, I guess. But what I love about that story is two things, right? One, again, we see influence, right?
我的朋友能看到所有其他人在开非常相似的车。唯独当把这束光照向他自己的行为时，他却看不见了。当时影响力是隐形的。但第二，这不仅仅是做同样的事情。这不仅仅是购买完全相同的车，也不是要做到完全不同。这是要在相似的同时保持不同。因此，影响力有多种风味，它们常常隐形地影响着我们的行为。你探讨的有趣观点之一是，社会影响力可能会对创新产生影响，
My friend could see all the other people driving very similar cars. It's that one that light shown on his own behavior, he couldn't see it. Then it was invisible. There the influence was invisible. But second, it wasn't just about doing the same thing. It wasn't just about buying the exact same car, and it wasn't about being completely different. It's about being similar and different at the same time. And so there are many flavors of influence that often invisibly affect our behavior. One of the interesting ideas you explore is that social influence can have implications for innovation,
因为这表明，如果我们受到周围人的塑造，那么某种在某些方面过于超前或与我们周围看到的规范差异太大的想法，可能会很难被采纳。你能给我讲讲1899年被称为“无马马车”的发明的故事吗？这是我在为本书做研究时偶然发现的一个惊人的故事。事实证明，当汽车问世时，在今天这个我们随时都能看到汽车的时代，这很难让人想起来。但当它们刚问世时，人们感到非常害怕。人们从未见过没有马拉的马车。想象一下这个东西，几乎就像一个幽灵
because it suggests that if we are shaped by those around us, then an idea that in some ways is too far ahead or too different from the norms that we see around us might have a difficult time getting adopted. Can you tell me the story of the 1899 invention known as horsey horseless? This is an amazing story that I came across while doing for research for the book. It turns out that when automobiles came out, it's hard to remember that in today's day and age when we see automobiles all the time. But when they first came out, they were very scary. People had never seen a non-horse driven carriage. Imagine this thing, almost like a ghost
独自在街上滚动。没有马拉它，没有人在拉它。农村地区的人们称之为魔鬼的杰作，并禁止它进入城镇。因此人们试图弄清楚，我们该如何让人们接受这个东西？它在某些方面显然节省了成本。街上有大量的粪便。
rolling down the street by itself. No horse pulling it, no person pulling it. People in rural areas called it the Devil's work and band it from town. And so people were trying to figure, well, how do we get this thing adopted? It obviously saved costs in certain way. There was a huge amount of manure on the street.
所以在某种程度上摆脱马匹是件好事。它们可以行驶得更远。他们如何才能让人们接受这种新创新呢？有趣的是，挑战并非功能性的。并非产品不能运作。而是一个心理问题。产品本身没问题，但他们必须克服它让人感觉过于不同的心理障碍。
So getting rid of horses was good in some ways. They could travel further. How could they get people to adopt this new innovation? And what's interesting is the challenge wasn't a functional one. It wasn't that the product didn't work. It was a psychological one. The product was fine, but they had to overcome it feeling too different.
事实上，这有点像金凤花姑娘和三只熊的故事，如果你仔细想想的话。一端是过于不同。如果某样东西太不同了。它就很吓人。我们不想接受它。它离得太远了。与此同时，如果某样东西与人们正在做的事情
And indeed, it's a little bit like Goldilocks and the three bears, if you think about it. One end is too different. It's something's too different. It's scary. We don't want to adopt it. It's too far away. If at the same time something exactly the same as what people
完全一样，人们又不想接受它。为什么我要为一个完全相同的东西改变我的行为呢？但在中间的那个刚好合适。如果愿意的话，它可以被称为“最佳独特性”。因此，回到汽车上来，这位发明家想出了一个非常有趣的想法来解决这个问题。他曾提出过许多创新，包括为处于某种腿部石膏固定状态中的学生设计的一张桌子，
are doing, people don't want to adopt it. Why do I need to change my behavior for something that's exactly the same? But in the middle is just right. It is what might be called optimally distinct, if you will. And so going back to the automobile, this inventor came up with a really interesting idea to solve this problem. And he had come up with many innovations, including a desk for students in a sort of a leg cast
以帮助人们在受伤后恢复。他说，天哪，你知道，如果问题是心理上的，我有个主意。于是他推出了这项名为“无马马车”的创新，本质上就是把一个假马头放在汽车的前面。你看着这个东西，然后你会说，为什么一个假马头会有助于人们接受汽车？但它所做的是，它让这种不同感觉更熟悉，让它感觉更相似，对吧？
to help people to recover after injuries. He said, God, you know, if the problem is psychological, I have an idea. So he came out with this innovation called the horsey horseless, which is essentially taking a fake horse head and putting it on the front of an automobile. And you look at this thing and you say, why would a fake horse head be anywhere near useful in helping people adopt an automobile? But what it did is it made the different feel more familiar, made it feel more similar, right?
它只是一个假马头，但它让它看起来像人们已经习惯的那些车辆。当这个东西停在当天的停车标志或红绿灯旁时，它让马儿们（指马车使用者）感觉更自在。它让人们对这种差异感到更加熟悉。
It was just a fake horse head, but it made it look like these vehicles that people were used to already. It made horses feel more comfortable and this thing pulled up next to them at the stop sign or the stop light of the day if it were. It made people feel more familiar with the difference.
所以这种“最佳独特性”的概念真的很重要。不能太不同。如果差异太大，人们会感到害怕。他们不想接受它。它太吓人了。它是新鲜事物。你知道，我为什么要这么做？
And so this idea of optimal distinctness is really important. Not so different. If it's so different, people are scared. They don't want to adopt it. It's scary. It's new. You know, why do I want to do this thing?
如果太相似也是如此。但在中间，那就刚刚好。在中间，它是最佳独特性的，并且更有可能流行起来。因此，当我阅读书中的这一部分时，我立刻开始思考无人驾驶汽车，以及许多人对似乎能自动驾驶的汽车所抱有的担忧和顾虑。我的意思是，谈谈机器里的幽灵。我想到了人们有时会让这些人体模特和他们坐在车里，给人们一种印象，即
Same if it's too similar. But in the middle, and it's just right. In the middle, it's optimally distinct and much more likely to catch on. So as I was reading this section of the book, I started thinking immediately about driverless cars and the concerns and trepidations that many people have about cars that seem to drive themselves. I mean, talk about ghosts in the machine. And I was thinking about people sometimes have these mannequins that sit in the car with them to give people the impression that
车里有人陪着他们。因此，如果你是一个女人，在夜晚开车穿过城市街道，你想给别人一种错觉，即车里不只有你一个人，你可能对犯罪的防御力更强，你的旁边就会坐着这个人体模特。我意识到我们应该做的是把人体模特放在驾驶座上。如果你这么做了，那基本上就会成为我们版本的“无马马车”。这几乎就像一个出租司机。虽然它是一个人体模特。我喜欢这个主意。你应该写信给谷歌和优步并提出这个建议。我想，但话说回来，你的想法确实很正确。
they're someone in the car with them. So if you're a woman driving through a city street at night and you want to give people the illusion that you're not alone in the car and you're maybe less vulnerable to crime, you have this mannequin sitting next to you. And I realized what we should do is take the mannequin and put the mannequin in the driver's seat. And if you did that, that's essentially going to be our version of horsey horse list. It's almost like a taxi driver. It's after it's a mannequin. I love that idea. You should write to Google and Uber and suggest it. I think, but again, you're thinking really correct about it.
无人驾驶汽车不必看起来像一辆车。如果它唯一的功用就是把我们从A点带到B点，为什么它必须看起来像一辆车？为什么它必须有方向盘？任何这些东西都不需要。但部分原因不仅在于功能。还在于心理学。它感觉安全吗？有一个人，即使是坐在里面的人体模特，
A driver's car doesn't have to look like a car. If all it's doing is getting us from point A to point B, why does it have to look like a car? Why does it have to have a steering wheel? Any of these things. But part of it is not just the function. It's the psychology. Does it feel safe? And having someone, even if it's a mannequin sitting in, it's the psychology, does it feel safe, and
这也是心理问题，它感觉安全吗？有一个人，即使是一个人体模特坐在驾驶座上，也可能会让我们觉得更舒服。接下来，我们将探讨隐形影响力如何影响我们对政治的看法。所以这里的简单观点是，党派往往凌驾于政策之上。即使是同一项政策，甚至是完全相同的实际事物，我们也会根据是谁在支持它来对该事物进行解读。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们今天与宾夕法尼亚大学的乔纳·伯杰进行了交谈。
having someone even if it's a mannequin sitting in the driver's seat might make us feel more comfortable. Coming up, we're going to explore how invisible influence affects the way we think about politics. So the simple idea here is it's often party over policy. Even the same policy, even the same actual thing, we interpret that thing based on who's supporting it. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're talking today with the University of Pennsylvania's Jonah Berger.
我们大多数人都相信，我们的政治观点是在经过仔细的思考和权衡后形成的。但最近有大量的社会科学研究表明，我们的观点在很大程度上是由社会背景塑造的。即使在我们对事实的理解方面，我们也会受到周围人思想和意见的偏见影响。我问乔纳·伯杰这是否属于隐形影响力世界的一部分。几年前，我的一位同事做了一项很棒的研究，
Most of us believe we come to our political views after careful thought and consideration. But there's been a lot of recent social science research that shows that our views are heavily shaped by social context. Even when it comes to our understanding of the facts, we're biased by the thoughts and opinions of those around us. I asked Jonah Berger if this was part of the world of invisible influence. A colleague of mine did a great study a few years ago
正是着眼于这一点。他给自由派和保守派都提供了一些不同的政策主张。其中一项是关于帮助弱势群体的。一项是关于税收的，还有一堆不同的政策。他告诉他们，这些政策要么得到民主党人的支持，要么得到共和党人的支持。他发现的情况非常符合你刚才提到的，即当保守派看到一项政策——同样的政策——如果他们认为该政策受到保守派的支持，他们就会非常喜欢这项政策。他们认为这太棒了。他们支持它。你知道，即使这
looking at exactly this. So he gave both liberals and conservatives a number of different policy propositions. So one was about helping disadvantaged people. One was about taxes, a bunch of different policies. And he told them that those policies were either supported by Democrats or Republicans. What he found very much along the lines of what you just mentioned is that when conservatives saw policy, the same policy, if they thought that policy was supported by conservatives, they loved the policy. They thought it was great. They supported it. You know, even if it
是一项福利政策，即使是一项慷慨的福利政策，由于保守派似乎很喜欢它，因为他们被告知其他保守派领袖支持它，他们就认为这太棒了。然而，如果同样的政策、同样的自由派福利政策是由自由派支持的，他们就会认为这太糟糕了。哦，自由派，他们总是做这种为福利着想的帮忙事。我完全、完全反对。同样的政策，完全不同的反应。自由派的做法完全一样。当自由派被告知某项政策得到自由派的支持时，
was a welfare policy, even if it was a generous welfare policy, the fact that conservatives seemed to like it, the fact they were told that other conservatives leaders supported, they thought it was great. They thought it was terrible, though, if that same policy, that same liberal welfare policy was supported by liberals. Oh, the liberals, they're always doing this, you know, helpful stuff for welfare. I'm totally, totally against it. Same policy, completely different reaction. Liberals did exactly the same thing. When liberals were told that policy was supported by liberals,
他们非常喜欢。当自由派被告知保守派喜欢该政策时，他们又讨厌它。所以这里的简单观点是，党派往往凌驾于政策之上。即使是同一项政策，甚至是完全相同的实际事物，我们也会根据是谁在支持它、根据它所暗示的身份来解读该事物。
they loved it. When liberals were told conservatives like the policy, they hated it. And so the simple idea here is it's often party over policy. Even the same policy, even the same actual thing, we interpret that thing based on who's supporting it, based on the identity, it signals.
这其实就在几个月前发生在我身上。当时我正在为一个组织做信息传递的咨询项目，该组织希望帮助清洁能源在保守派中流行起来。他们认为清洁能源是保守派会支持的东西。毕竟，它节省了税款，减少了政府的规模。这些都是保守派应该喜欢的东西，然而当他们调查保守派时，他们发现保守派并不支持清洁能源。
And this actually happened to me just a few months ago. So was doing a consulting project with messaging for an organization that wanted to help clean energy catch on among conservatives. And clean energy is something that they thought conservatives would support. After all, it saves tax dollars, it reduces the size of government. All things that conservatives should like, yet when they surveyed conservatives, they found that conservatives weren't supporting clean energy.
于是他们进行了更深入的挖掘，发现有一个明确的原因：当他们询问保守派、尤其是保守派领袖，为什么保守派领袖不支持该政策时，他们说，哦，是的，清洁能源、太阳能、风能，这难道不是阿尔·戈尔喜欢的东西吗？如果阿尔·戈尔喜欢它，它可能就不适合我。这里再次非常有趣的是，同样的政策，对吧？然而，仅仅因为它与像阿尔·戈尔这样杰出的自由派联系在一起，
And so they dug a little deeper and they found that there was a clear reason why, when they asked conservatives, particularly conservative leaders, why conservative leaders weren't supporting the policy, they said, oh, yeah, clean energy, solar power, wind power, well, isn't that something that Al Gore likes? And if Al Gore likes it, it's probably not for me. And what's so interesting there again is same policy, right? Yet the mere fact that was associated with a prominent liberal like Al Gore
就让他们不想去做了。因此，我们确实需要思考政治，不仅要思考实际的政治，还要思考身份认同的政治。参与某种行为意味着什么？做某事或不做某事对我是什么暗示？我们如何利用这一点来帮助人们做正确的事情？我的意思是，有很多政治学家将我们与政党的附属关系比作我们对各种运动队的的支持。所以我是某支足球队的忠实粉丝，
made them not want to do it. And so we really need to think about the politics, not just of actual politics, but the politics of identity. What does it mean to engage in a certain behavior? What does it signal about me to do something or not do something? And how can we use that to help people do better things? I mean, there are a lot of political scientists who talk about our affiliation with political parties as being very analogous to our support for various sports teams. So I'm a devout fan
当然，每年这支球队的球员都会换人，当效力于该球队的所有人都换了时，支持这支球队完全是理性的。但杰瑞·宋飞有一句名言：我们真正支持的是球衣（Laundry），在某种程度上，我们在政治上也是这么做的。我的意思是，我们真正做的其实是在支持球衣。我喜欢“支持球衣”这个短语，
of a football team. And of course, every year, the players on that team change, and it's completely rational to support the team when all the people playing for the team have changed. But there's a famous line from Jerry Seinfeld, what we're really doing is we're rooting for Laundry, and at some level, we're doing that with politics too. I mean, what we're really doing is we're rooting for Laundry. I love that phrase rooting for Laundry,
当然，这也是其中的一部分，对吧？部分原因在于它感觉像是一种团队身份。其中也包含一些信息，对吧？有这样一种观念，天哪，如果过去很多与我有类似感受的人都喜欢并支持这个，我也要喜欢并支持它，对吧？如果我走过一家餐馆，前面排着长长的队伍，我就会认为那家餐馆一定更好。政治也是如此，对吧？
and certainly, that's part of it, right? Part of it is it feels like a team identity. There's also some information there, right? There's this notion that God, if a lot of people that I feel similarly to in the past, it's like this and support this, I'm going to like it and support it too, right? If I walk by a restaurant and there's a long line out in front, I assume that restaurant must be better. Same thing with politics, right?
如果政党变了，或者，你知道的，政党的观点变了，但每个人仍然认为它是他们所知道和喜爱的那个相同的组织，有时最终就会盲目跟风。你知道的，几个月前，我们在《隐藏的大脑》中引用了你的另一项研究。它与以下可能性有关：
If the party changes, or, you know, the party views change, but everyone still thinks it's that same organization that they know and love, sometimes end up following the wrong thing. You know, a few months ago, we cited one of your other studies on Hidden Brain. It had to do with the likelihood
赢得篮球比赛，以及中场休息时的比分是多少。我必须说，我非常喜欢这项研究。你能告诉我们你是怎么做这项研究的吗？以及中场休息时的比分是多少。我必须说，我非常喜欢这项研究。你能告诉我们你是怎么做这项研究的以及它发现了什么吗？我曾经是一名足球教练，而这其实就是灵感的来源。所以我去了加利福尼亚的斯坦福大学读研究生和本科，从小就酷爱足球，所以我决定当一名教练。所以我执教了AYSO，某种程度上，你知道的，就是足球少年联盟。“教练”这个词其实有点勉强。我基本上是在照看15、12岁的男孩，
of winning basketball games, and what the score was at halftime. I have to say, I absolutely love this study. Can you tell us how you came to do the study, and what the score was at halftime. I have to say, I absolutely love this study. Can you tell us how you came to do the study and what it found? I used to be a soccer coach, and this is where it actually came from. So I went to a graduate school in undergrad in California at Stanford, loved soccer growing up, and so I decided to become a coach. So I coached AYSO, sort of, you know, the little league of soccer. Coach is generous, by the way. I was basically sort of shepherding, 15, 12-year-old boys
并试图阻止他们在每周两次、每次一个半小时的时间里打架。但我们会进行训练，我们会努力变得更好。希望他们在这一过程中学到了一两件事。但当比赛来临时，我注意到了一个奇怪的现象。我们是一支不错的球队。我们不是最棒的球队。但我们是一支不错的球队。
and trying to stop them from fighting for an hour and a half twice a week. But we'd run drills and we'd try to get better. And hopefully they learned one or two things along the way. But when it came time to games, I noticed something weird. We were a good team. We weren't the best team out there. We were a good team.
然而当中场休息时我们落后时，我们似乎总能找到赢球的方法。所以如果我们落后一球，我们就能以二比一反超取胜。甚至落后两球。有时我们也能赢。我们落后零比二。我们可以三比二取胜。我们总能找到扭转局势的方法。
But when we were behind at halftime, we always seem to figure out a way to win. So if we were down by a goal, we'd win two-one. We'd down two goals even. Sometimes we'd win. We're down to zero. We'd win three to two. We always figured out a way to pull it out.
而在其他时候，如果我们打平或者领先，我们有时反而会想出输球的方法。所以我当时只是想弄明白，天哪，我到底哪里做错了？如果我们能后来居上，难道我们不应该一直赢吗？因此，我和我的一个好朋友、一位优秀的同事德文·波普（他现在在芝加哥大学）一起，去收集了成千上万场职业篮球比赛的数据。我们收集了一堆NCAA比赛，一堆NBA比赛，基本上我们进行了观察和研究，
And other times, if we were tied or we were ahead, we sometimes figured out a way to lose. And so I was just trying to figure out, God, what am I doing wrong? If we can come from behind, shouldn't we win all the time? So with a friend of mine, great colleague of mine, Devon Pope, he's now at the University of Chicago, we went out and got tens of thousands of professional basketball games. We got a bunch of NCAA games, a bunch of NBA games, and essentially we looked and said,
好吧，中场休息时的比分与比赛结束时的比分有何关联？换句话说，如果在半场时一支球队领先或落后，会如何影响他们最终是赢还是输？和我的少年足球队类似，希望数据能更丰富一些。有趣的是，顺便说一句，希望他们的动力也能更足一些。如果你是一名NBA球员，你拿到的是几千万美元的薪水，
OK, how does the score at halftime relate to the score at the end of the game? So how does if a team is ahead or behind at half time affect whether or not they win or lose? Similar to my youth soccer team, it's hopefully a little more data. And interestingly, by the way, hopefully a little more motivated. If you're an NBA player, you're getting tens of millions of dollars
这取决于你的表现。所以你可能会说，好吧，如果你是一个12岁的孩子，你的教练可能会选择你并鼓励你更努力地踢球，你更有可能获胜。但这对于NBA球员来说应该不重要，对吧？我的意思是，NBA球员，利害关系重大，不管他们赢还是输，他们赚的钱会有所增减。当然，这在那里应该不重要，对吧？所以这正是我们想要去查看的。
based on your performance. So you might say, OK, if you're a 12-year-old kid, your coach could choose you and encourage you to play harder, you're more likely to win. But it shouldn't matter for NBA players, right? I mean, NBA players, real big stakes, whether they win or lose, they make more or less money. Of course, it doesn't matter there, right? So that's what we wanted to look at.
于是我们查看了数据，和足球一样，我们看到了一个非常有趣的情况，那就是存在这样一个场景：落后实际上是一件好事。那就是只落后一点点的时候。半场落后一分的球队，并没有像其他人落后时那样更有可能输球。他们实际上更有可能赢球。落后一分的球队比领先一分的球队更有可能获胜。
And so we looked at the data, and similar to soccer, we saw something really interesting, which is there was one place where being behind was actually a good thing. And that was being behind by just a little bit. Teams that were down by one and a half time, they weren't more likely to lose as everyone else would have been if they were behind. They were actually more likely to win. Teams that were down by one were more likely to win
尽管他们是更弱的队伍，但相比于领先一分的球队，落后两分意味着他们需要进更多的球才能取胜。他们在下半场表现得更加努力，更有可能赢得比赛。事实证明，竞争可以影响动力，对吧？我们相对于其他人的表现如何是很重要的。
than teams that were up by one. Even though they were worst teams, down by two points, relative to the teams that were up by one, they had to score more to win. They came out, they played harder in the second half, and they were more likely to win the game. And so it turns out that competition can affect motivation, right? How we're doing relative to others matters.
所以落后可以成为一种动力，但前提是你只落后了一点点。如果你落后太多，你就会放弃，并且更有可能直接躺平。所以我要告诉你，乔纳，自我开始了解许多研究和观点以来，已经过去十多年了，当我最初接触到其中许多研究时，我真的大吃一惊，因为我认为自己是一个非常理性、审慎和有意识的人，而我的行动、信仰或判断正在被这些潜藏在许多情况下超出我意识层面的因素所塑造这一想法，对我来说真是一个令人不安的想法。我必须说，有趣的是，在直觉层面上，我仍然觉得
And so being behind can be motivating, but only if you're behind by a little bit. If you're behind by too much, you give up and you're more like it quick. So I have to tell you, Jonah, that it's been a little more than a decade since I began learning about many of the studies and ideas, and I was really taken aback by many of them when I first came by them because I think of myself as being a very rational and deliberate and intentional person, and the idea that my own actions or beliefs or judgments were being shaped by these factors that lie, many cases outside my conscious awareness, was sort of a really disturbing idea to me. I have to say what's interesting is that at an intuitive level, it still feels to me that
我所有的决定和判断都是有意识的、蓄意的和深思熟虑的。除了你看到如山的证据，你不得不承认，如果它正在影响地球上所有这些其他人，它也一定在影响我。我觉得这项研究的一大价值在于，它可能会促使人们具备某种程度的谦逊，去承认：是的，我对所支持的政党感觉非常强烈。我对所支持的运动队感觉非常强烈。我对自己的信仰感觉非常强烈，但完全有可能的是，这些信仰实际上是由这些其他因素塑造的，我可能需要对自己自以为知道的事情保持一点谦逊。
all my decisions and judgments are conscious and intentional and deliberate. I don't feel the effects of social pressure except that you look at the mountain of evidence and you have to say, if it's affecting all these other people on the planet, it must be affecting me as well. And I feel like one of the great values of this body of research is it might prompt people to a certain degree of humility of saying, yes, I feel very strongly about the political party I support. I feel very strongly about the sports day in my support. I feel very strongly about my beliefs, but it's just possible that maybe these beliefs are actually shaped by these other factors and I might want to be a little humble about the things that I think I know.
我想知道，当你审视这堆研究成果时，它对你个人产生了什么影响？当你看到人类被其他人塑造的种种方式时，它对你的个人生活产生了什么影响？你知道的，当你阅读这些文献并在此文献基础上做一些研究时，你几乎会经历一场存在主义危机。你会说，天哪，你知道的，我没有做出任何自己的选择。其他人替我做出了所有这些选择。难道没有自由意志吗？
I'm wondering as you've looked at this body of work, what's been the effect on you personally? What's been the effect on your personal life as you look at all the ways in which human beings are shaped by other people? You know, you read this literature and you do some studies in this literature and you can almost have an existential crisis. You can say, God, you know, I'm not making any of my own choices. Other people are making all these things for me. Is there no free will?
我难道只是一个毫无思想的自动机吗？我的意思是，举个极好的例子，这是一直让我感触颇深的事。你知道，想想我们结婚的那个人。想想我们结婚的那个人，或者最终成为我们长期伴侣、恋爱伴侣的那个人。我们所有人都有这样一种感觉，觉得他们对我们来说是完美的。我们都相信真爱，相信我们能在外面找到合适的人，
Am I just a mindless automaton? I mean, you know, take a great example and this is something that always struck me. You know, think about the person that we marry me. Think about the person that we marry, or the person that we end up being our long-term partner, or our relationship partner. We all have this sense that they're perfect for us. We all have this belief in true love, and that we're finding the right person out there
那个能让我们完整的人，那只鞋完美契合的那个人，那个能让我们完整的人。然而，这是真的吗？真的有这么一个人，而我们只需要找到他们吗？还是说我们正潜移默化地受到环境的影响？我们喜欢他们是因为我们更常见到他们吗？所以我们增加了对他们的接触。
that completes us, that the one person who's shoe perfectly fits the one person who will make us whole. And yet, is that right? Is it there's the one person out there and we just have to find them? Or are we subtly being influenced by our environment? Did we like them because we saw them more often? And so we got exposed to them more.
因此，仅仅是接触就会产生好感，我们是受到了环境的影响，还是真的是自己做出的选择？有一段时间，我个人觉得这是一件让我苦苦挣扎的事情。想想看，嗯，我们真的是自己做选择吗？如果我们不自己做选择，
And so mere exposure leads to liking, where we influenced by our environment or do we really make our own choice? And for a while, I think personally, that was something I struggled with a lot. Thank you about, we'll do we really make our own choice. And for a while, I think personally, that was something I struggled with a lot. Think about, you know, well, do we really make our choices? And if we don't make our choices,
那对我们是谁意味着什么？老实说，我不确定我是否得到了一个完美的答案，但我认为我最终得出的结论是，影响力本身既不好也不坏。它只是生活中的一种方式。它是帮助我们让生活更轻松的事物。想象一下，如果我们必须自己做出每一个选择。我们无法利用任何来自其他人的信息。
what does that mean about who we are? And I'm not sure I got to a perfect answer, honestly, but I think where I ended up is, you know, influenced by itself is neither good nor bad. It is just a way of life. It is a thing that helps us make our lives easier. Imagine if we had to make every choice by ourselves. We couldn't use any information from others.
我们无法弄清楚该读哪本书或看哪部电影。如果我们搬到一个新城镇，如果不看在线评论，我们就无法弄清楚该去哪个汽车修理厂。如果我们必须完全靠自己摸索。生活将会极其艰难。因此，在漫长的过程中，我们进化出了利用社交信息的能力，将他人当作启发式方法或判断的捷径，使生活变得更轻松，
We couldn't figure out what book to read or what movie to see. If we moved to a new town, we couldn't figure out what car mechanic to go to without looking at an online review. We had to just figure it out by ourselves. Life would be extremely difficult. And so along the way, we've evolved to take advantage of social information, to use others as heuristic or a shortcut to judgment to make it easier to live,
比原本可能经历的要更快、更容易。这种启发式方法总是能指引我们找到正确的答案吗？不会。有许多情况下，其中一些是我们讨论过的，其他人把我们引入歧途，但大多数时候，影响力是一种宝贵的工具。因此，我认为我们越是意识到它对我们的影响，我们就能越好地发现周围环境中的它，我们就能过得更快乐、更健康。
you know, faster and easier than it might be otherwise. Does that heuristic always lead us to the right answer? No. There are many cases, you know, some of which we've talked about, where other people lead us to stray, yet most of the time influence is a valuable tool. And so I think the more we realize it's a fact on us, the more we can spot it in the environment around us, the happier and healthier we can be.
我们无法完全控制它。它将一直存在，但我们对它理解得越多，就越能利用它的积极面并避开它的消极面。乔纳·伯杰，我想感谢你今天与我交谈。很高兴你能来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。本期《隐藏的大脑》由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）制作和剪辑。我们的团队包括
We can't fully control it. It's going to be there all the time, but the more we understand it, the more we can take advantage of its upsides and avoid its downsides. Juna Berger, I want to thank you for talking with me today. It's been a pleasure having you on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes
玛吉·佩恩曼（Maggie Penman）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）和雷妮·克拉克（Renee Clark）。我们本周的幕后英雄是达娜·法林顿（Dana Farrington）。达娜是 NPR.org 的编辑，她是将最优秀的公共广播故事转化为网络受众内容的奇才。我们最近请达娜协助我们为节目中的一个新职位面试候选人。达娜深思熟虑的反馈和冷静的 demeanor（举止）帮助我们挑选出了合适的人选。谢谢你，达娜，我们希望你很快能投桃报李。在我们结束之前还有最后一件事，我们希望听到那些忙得甚至连呼吸时间都没有的听众的心声。
Maggie Penman, Jenny Schmidt and Renee Clark. Our unsung hero this week is Dana Farrington. Dana is an editor at NPR.org and she's a whiz that translate in the best of public radio storytelling for a web audience. We recently asked Dana to help us interview candidates for a new position on our show. Dana's thoughtful feedback and calm demeanor helped us pick the right person. Thanks Dana, we hope you can return the favor soon. One last thing before we go, we're hoping to hear from listeners who are so busy, they barely have time to breathe.
Maggie Penman、Jenny Schmidt和Renee Clark。我们本周的无名英雄是Dana Farrington。Dana是NPR.org的一名编辑，她是个天才，能将最棒的公共广播故事完美转化为网络受众喜爱的内容。我们最近请Dana帮我们面试新岗位的候选人。Dana深思熟虑的反馈和冷静的作风帮我们选对了人。谢谢你，Dana，希望你不久后能礼尚往来。在我们结束之前还有最后一件事，我们希望能听到那些忙得几乎连喘气时间都没有的听众的心声。
Have you found yourself dealing with spiraling challenges simply because you haven't had time to deal with routine chores like going to the DMV or getting a leak fixed in your home? If you have a story of how not attending to the small staff ballooned into a disaster, call and leave us a message. We might feature you on an upcoming show. The number to call is 661-772-7246. That's 66177 Brain. And thanks. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你是否曾发现自己陷入一连串不断恶化的挑战中，仅仅是因为你没有时间处理车管所（DMV）办事或修理家中漏水等日常琐事？如果你有关于未能处理小事最终滚雪球般演变成灾难的故事，请打电话给我们留个言。我们可能会在接下来的节目中播出你的故事。拨打的电话号码是 661-772-7246。也就是 66177 Brain。谢谢大家。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。